[Music]  a test is an order  five enhanced clones more capable than  an army  yet they exhibit a concerning level of  disobedience  in this regard for orders  what else you've got give me more  our squad's nothing but trouble  but we get the job done  you're climb force 99 you know who we  are  hunter let's go  echo hyperdrive's online tick prepping  to jump  ricken  [Music]  i want clone force 99 found and wiped  out  the galaxy's a dangerous place to be  we need to get out of here  what do you say kid you want to come  with us how can i help  the clone wars have ended  you can either adapt and survive  or die with the past  the decision is yours  we do what we do  strapping kid  [Music]  you